[Musique]
une veste rouge pour un invité de marque
la députée aurore bergé a convié à ses
voeux le président de l'assemblée
nationale françois de rugy
une cérémonie sous le signe de la
collaboration entre la députée et les
élus locaux sur cinquante et une commune
ce soir elles toutes les communes
étaient représentées par l'intermédiaire
de leurs élus locaux
il y avait plus 30 mer ce soir ce qui
veut dire quand même qu'on a réussi à
créer un lien sur ce territoire
un bloc communal venus avec des
revendications sur la baisse des
dotations de l'état
et cet argent évidemment qui est prélevé
sur les coûts de fonctionnement le maire
de maurepas grégory cariste ya échangé
avec le président de l'assemblée
nationale notamment sur la prochaine
réforme de la constitution
une réforme sur laquelle l'élu sera
vigilant les collectivités
les intercommunalités les communes les
départements et les régions ont été
mises à mal ces dernières années avec
une baisse de financement drastique qui
entachent depuis très longtemps
maintenant la libre administration des
collectivités
françois de rugy a profité de la tribune
pour présenter sa vision de la réforme
constitutionnelle
la réforme de la constitution c'est en
effet l'occasion de donner plus de
liberté aux collectivités locales
si on veut que les collectivités locales
soient plus efficaces face des économies
disons le eh bien il faut leur donner
davantage de liberté et d'autonomie dans
leur gestion notamment dans leur gestion
du personnel et puis faut aussi être
capable d'innover
on n'est pas obligé d'administrer la
france de la même façon quand on est en
milieu rural en montagne dans une zone
touristique ou dans une grande ville
cette réforme voulue par le président de
la république devrait être présenté au
printemps
deux options sont possibles pour
l'adopter le vote à la majorité des
trois cinquièmes des parlementaires
réunis en congrès où un référendum